this morning on a special edition of the
dish the focus isn't on food but on a
very special beverage orange wine along
with other forms of alcohol retail sales
of wine have exploded since the corona
virus pandemic began according to data
from Nielsen wine sales were up by over
30 percent in March and April compared
to the same period the year before
as Jamie wax tells us some of those
sales include a type of wine that's
neither red white nor rose a you're
trying to find that magic combination
when it comes to wine making we are
about two-thirds of the way through
Artie Wallace isn't afraid to be a
little different exuberant and jubilant
that's the most incredible thing I think
that California has going for it in the
wine world so we don't have any rules
that ethos fuels wallets a winemaker and
partner at dirty and rowdy family winery
past the point of no return like we were
just like he's become part of a
fast-growing trend in the industry by
making something old new again orange
wine by leaving these skins on it's the
same music I'm just gonna go and adjust
the volumes so we're gonna take this
from four and we're gonna take this to
set sometimes you want to take that in
your guitar players grapes that would
typically be pressed and fermented
without their skins to make white wine
are instead fermented with their skins
on resulting in a wine with a golden hue
it's a winemaking method that originated
in the region that is now the Republic
of Georgia thousands of years ago
people they see orange and they
automatically think of the fruit once we
get past that point they think of a
white wine left in the skins is gonna be
sweet it's gonna be light it's gonna be
all these things that it's not no orange
wine is usually heavier it's more dense
more tannic or mouth-filling
we visited Wallace last winter at Sugar
Loaf crush a shared winery space in
Sonoma County and now we've got what's
left of these grape skins and I'll tell
you if you told me that these were
olives I would believe it let's do it
the winemaking process required some
legwork I'm having memories of I Love
Lucy here hearty this is it
just step in you can put your butt right
on the edge right okay Wow
oh what a feeling with all the
automation in winemaking why is it still
important for this to be done by a human
foot a lot of people would say this is
crazy this is ridiculous
but you're making much larger quantities
of wines this is something as I
mentioned this will make 600 bottles
stomping grapes with you it feels like
we're part of an ancient ritual an
ancient process that's the magic of it
so what do we have happening here all
those grapes that we had drained that we
had stomped we're squeezing out that
last 20% or so of juice that's coming
out while our grapes were in the press
we headed to the barrel room it's not
orange to taste the 2018 skin fermented
Simeon harvest 2018 in so many ways the
best one ever named one of the best
orange wines in the world what would you
pair this wine with an empty glass I
think that's the beautiful thing you're
so versatile like you have this with
scallops and it kills it because we've
got incredible acidity but we also have
just enough tannin to work with kind of
that fleshiness of the scallop you take
this and have like I think a chips and
salsa and like you've got a good night I
like your approach to wine hearty to see
a category like this actually centuries
old suddenly get on the radar globally
right how rare is that I would say it's
very rare
Sam stopple more is the wine director at
company divan so naturelle in New York
an outpost of the renowned Paris wine
bar Peter Vader mal Berg one of the
great producers we paid him a visit
earlier this year to ask about orange
wines rising popularity this was really
looked at until a few years ago at least
certainly in the US as a sort of peasant
tradition a peasant wine right it was
not a high-end style of wine right I
think that's kind of a trend throughout
this sort of high-low
you know black truffles with Crooklyn
sort of sandwich or caviar and potato
chips kind of thing but I think you're
seeing this trend of like these rustic
kind of local styles like oh there's a
reason they've done this
thousands of years they're actually very
delicious we tasted a few of the 30
varieties of orange wine stopple more
offers here including the Oneko Zelo
esoteric Oh a blend from Australia that
retails at about $23 hmm good
that is fantastic yeah there's just this
energy - you taste so many wines and
like there's only so many times you can
say apple and pear and lemon or whatever
right but there's a feeling you get you
get a feeling when you hear funky jazz
or soul or blues I don't see why you
can't have those same feelings when
you're smelling or tasting wine it's
such a like ephemeral like sensory
object next the sell Bach oyster oMG
Riesling from Germany with a price tag
of $30 whoa you get that texture right
away but then bone-dry the pandemic has
forced the bars wine tastings and
classes online on the west coast Hardy
Wallace has also gone virtually realized
this is not a regular virtual tasting
with weekly tasting and music events a
way to bring wine lovers together and
keep dirty and rowdy going after a lack
of restaurant sales due to Kovac 19 cost
the company half of its annual revenue
there's still hope that increased
interest in orange wine will translate
into sales for smaller vintners you
don't see a lot of large wineries making
orange wine for small producers like us
it's a huge opportunity to reach people
far and wide it's really a gala terian
where it's not a luxury product and it's
not just a hipster drink it's one of
these things that I think allows people
to have just a full body experience
drinking a glass of wine Cheers it's
orange wine - orange wine plenty of
reasons for a toast for CBS this morning
Saturday that's the reaction ya know it
makes you want to do new wax
santa rosa california cheers and i'm not
gonna get up and dance but i really like
it it's almost citrusy and it's drier
than I thought it's it is for me I like
it Cheers
very tannic very dry you're right
citrusy Dana but worth worth trying for
sure